and of course testing is key to finding
out exactly how many Americans have the
coronavirus and estates rush to do more
tests commercial labs are struggling to
keep up with the pace results are still
pending for tens of thousands of tests
because of a nationwide backlog our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
investigating and she spoke to one man
who waited more than a week for his
results - Rico good morning good morning
to you you know simply put there is a
backlog in some places and the Michigan
man that we spoke to said that he waited
longer than expected for his results and
it was his family who happened to go
online and sort of stumble upon those
results and it's not just the sick
people that this waiting game if you
will is impacting hospital officials say
that that is also costing them valuable
resources I think you want to know
what's going on with your body and then
what you might be facing you know
further ahead Mike offer says he was
left without answers for eight days
after taking a kovin 19 tests oh you're
in this constant worry of you know is
you know he's gonna wake up in the
morning because he didn't wake up in the
middle of the night gasping for air his
wife Lisa said the lack of information
also left friends and family wondering
if they were exposed in the meantime not
only can we not get answers we can't
give answers to our employers to our
friends to our family people that we had
been around in the couple weeks before
Mike's test was administered by his
local urgent care but even national
groups like LabCorp are reporting
turnaround times of four to five days
and quest Diagnostics tell CBS this
morning it is still working to clear 80
thousand tests from its backlog that's
down from 160,000 tests nearly two weeks
ago should the private laboratories be
doing more I think everybody needs to be
doing more and then private labs are a
part of the solution my sense is that
they are working as hard as they can
dr. Ashish Jha is the director of the
Harvard Global Health Institute about
testing you don't know how much disease
there is you can't isolate people who
are infected you can't make treatment
plans for
people who are infected hospital
officials say testing also helps them
manage resources like bet availability
and personal protective equipment or PPE
when it comes down to lab testing
turnaround time is dr. Jeff Baird is the
acting chair of laboratory medicine at
UW Medicine in Seattle he says the
hospital's in-house testing can process
results within hours which helps them
save valuable resources for the
hospitalized patient or the patient
evaluated in the emergency room or a
clinic we need to treat all of those
patients when they come in as if they
have it because if they do we need to be
protected and if they don't we can then
relax our PPE standards and treat them
in a more appropriate way but it's not
just private companies struggling to
keep up as of Sunday more than 14,000
people in California are waiting test
results from both private and public
health labs many other states have yet
to report specific numbers on testing
backlogs inconsistencies between states
inspired the Kovach tracking project
which collects all the data state by
state in one place Alexis Madrigal a
writer for The Atlantic is a co-founder
we feel like if you're part of the
National Response this epidemic then you
owe the nation transparency what we need
from them is not perfection
but transparency honesty and openness
both quest and LabCorp tell CBS this
morning that they have increased their
testing capacity right now both
companies say they're testing around
35,000 each day and combined both
companies have run more than 1 million
tests Tony but still more work to do
Rica thank you very much